un gainage vous avez 70 bien à lui est
bien mais bien la phase aller il est
coriace monte cristo il est coriace
ouais alors donc ça acteurs on a vu le
business et les revenir dans les
affaires l'on finit aulas à mon réseau
heureux de facteurs ah bon je fais du
théâtre tous les ans à paris l'année
d'après en province je fais 4 5
valence par an je suis vachement heureux
et j'ai découvert une activité avec le
théâtre qui est unique
ah ouais moi je vous ai vu sur scène
c'est chiant mais j'ai pu croire beau
[ __ ] et ça fait drôle à être heureux
autant que s'abat alors c'est ça il fait
ça paraît que nous alors le business non
le sport et les revenir dans le sport
oui parce que ça c'est un truc l'ol je
reprendrai om nom leur elle marche bien
vous êtes sur lci dans onze matches mais
ça c'est marrant j'ai un barème assez
d'épreuves et dès que vous n'êtes pas là
l'émission allah vous les avez accroché
une drogue dure
bah ouais je dis que vous n'êtes pas
dans les champs l'opacité des
journalistes assez compétent matraque
tout le monde et qui crache tout le
monde les joueurs les clubs les
dirigeants et tout est là moi je suis
arrivé pour les casser ou un peu pour
leur dire attendez vous dit des
conneries et tout donc les gens se
marrent évidemment comment ça va bernard
et de pascal praud très bien vous êtes a
mis un pain joli mais on va très bien
depuis 1 4 ghz est de fait vous êtes
réconcilier avec pascal praud oui un bon
j'avais été fâché on pense pas mais
chouette hulotte
passat un bourre-pif entre amis enfin
franchement y'a pas de quoi faire quand
c'est vrai bernard qu'ils allaient
reprendre le red star pour faire une
deuxième équipe parisienne c'est ce que
j'aimerais faire
ah ça serait bien que c'est une vraie
équipe de banlieue elle et elle a une
histoire extraordinaire azul à
saint-ouen
par conséquent pas loin du stade de
france le jour on sera en première
division mais enfin ça y'a rien de fait
moi j'aimerais travailler avec eux voilà
ça serait bien mais pas forcément en
étant le t1
alors voilà et la politique alors non je
regarde qui revient non non non non non
sérieusement sérieusement je vais
revenir chez mes potes radicaux parce
que c'est vraiment des gens qui m'ont
soutenu tout le temps mais pour faire
comme chacun de ceux qui s'intéressent à
la politique sans être élu sa veste un
pays en france où je le faisais avant
avant je faisais toutes les émissions
politiques je n'étais pas élu
quand je me suis fait le pen je n'étais
pas élu non et j'ai été invité pour
parler avec lui pas gentiment d'ailleurs
est bon on a un problème patron de moi
donc on n'est pas obligé d'être élu pour
faire de la politique à coeur non
simplement les clients les bons clients
sont pas sont de son art ouais parce que
votre femme elle a dit toute façon s'il
refait de la politique j'ai du vent ce
oui bah oui elle a quand même beaucoup
souffert
oui elle était très courageuse un canton
compte en règle la cnds comme ça ouais
je comprends vous la trouviez pas en
fait ben voila je suis comme vous un et
malin hein
il a trouvé énorme il a trouvé quand
même je suis désolé et solide à elle est
courageuse quand même un dominique là
parce que midway
bon alors là maintenant la passer quand
même
et encore quand même quelques nuages
noirs bernard on va les évoquer vous
avez des ennemis vous le savez le cdr
quel organisme liquidateur des actifs de
l'ancien crédit lyonnais lui veulent en
cassation à le céder à ces dernières ils
disent non nous on n'accepte pas la
décision du tribunal donner à bernard
tapie 147 millions d'euros
nous on veut aller en cassation il dit
ça fait neuf ans finalement peut essayer
de gagner de trois ans de plus d'accord
en gros c'est la société de défaisance
du crédit grèce et ça a repris tous les
actifs et comme son nom l'indiqué ça
doit être quelque chose qu'à une vie xm
en cours fruits puisque sa loi trancher
les litiges ça doit vendre nos actifs et
trancher les litiges vers hébreu ils
sont encore là ils dépensent par parents
des centaines de millions d'euros
d'avocats a mis d'accord qui sont
toujours les mêmes à fait d'accord et
les avocats passent leur temps à
expliquer ce coup ci aurait grillé un an
les chaumes tous ces cultive life ils
ont pendant huit ans expliqué qu'ils
allaient gagner salle mt 500 millions
d'euros aux français
ouais et aujourd'hui c'est en train de
nous expliquer la en cassation va gagner
ouais alors bon ils peuvent durer encore
donna très dense et organismes là il ya
votre ami charles de courson
il est maintenant lien oui c'est un
député un député ump de la marne je
crois et il vous aime pas non et
pourquoi pas je dois pas être son genre
lui il a les fils du peuple c'est ça non
non je sais pas du tout je ne connais
pas bon il se trouvait là a mené un
combat qu'il poursuit avec toute sa
haine etc
moi je le rends pas je ne le connais pas
par contre ce qui est inquiétant
problèmes concernant ce personnage en
gros pour que les gens sachent c'est un
doctrinaire moraliste vivre en cassation
mais il veut faire l'amour atteint avant
le procès souvenez vous il y avait une
grande émission sur je sais plus si
c'est la cie sous la iii on appelle les
émission d'investigation sur le procès
aucun avocat
aucun et aucune partie ni moi ni adidas
avons accepté d'aller à cette émission
alors qu'on était à moi du délibéré
lui oui c est ça le dérange pas d'aller
fracassé de parler d'un sujet alors que
normalement
totalement interdite le tout pour
essayer de forcer la main aux magistrats
et puis là depuis que le jus moyens il
continue il commente le jeu il est
incroyable parce que quand on dit
bernard tapie pourrait revenir en
politique ce qui apparemment n'est pas
le cas lui il est déjà prévu il dit mais
bernard tapie pour la présidentielle par
exemple il trouvera jamais 500 signes à
la présidentielle tapie ne trouvera
jamais 506 mathieu riches il a dit par
exemple c'est que si on fait pas 5%
obligé de rembourser les frais de
campagne qui sont payés par lé
gouvernement dit mais si tapie ne fait
pas 5%
qui va payer les frais de campagne série
pensent déjà que j'allais à la
présidentielle et que vous n'aurez pas
les 500 signatures et que vous ne ferez
pas 5%
je crois qu'il est digne d'être dans
l'écurie de bayrou en fait ces [ __ ]
il est dans l'écurie de bayrou est oui
autre problème par rapport à l'avenir de
marc tapis et là ça n'a rien à voir avec
notre ami course on sait les affaires
pendantes c'est à dire la fraude fiscale
pour commencer alors vous on vous dit
voilà va falloir payer encore vous dit
attendez j'ai été déjà il est génial
j'ai été tellement sévèrement jugés non
mais ça ce sont toutes les affaires
pénales qui étaient suspendus au
résultat de la sphère civile très
conséquent maintenant que la sphère
civile est connu les magistrats ont
entre leurs mains les éléments
d'évaluation qui n'avaient pas je dois
dire que grâce à deux au parquet au
parquet général on a réussi à
interrompre un cycle infernal sans ça on
aurait pu rester encore cinq ans comme
ça à une question moi qui m'intéresse
c'est pendant toute cette période là
disons les dix dernières années pendant
que vous attendiez le procès en appel
finalement quels sont les gens qui vous
ont pas laissé tomber tous mes potes
genre
kouchner cgoea jacques lang le lait
borloo borloo
bien sûr ouais je me suis pas gouré sur
mes copains
bienvenue